[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
about today's podcast sponsors Tom's
outfit from Brooks Brothers
in today's Adam he's been up since four
o'clock in the morning Early Morning
Golf it's glowing anyway I can
legitimately say it's the first time in
my life that four o'clock in the morning
was the time that I woke up not going
well we're proud of you we just want to
say publicly we're proud of you nine
holes and what I'm even more proud of is
the drive what were their names Orlando
to here how fast were you going what's
the fastest he went honestly I hit a
hundred a couple Millions
were you shaking were you like I'm doing
just crying halfway no but you're you're
that we're alluding to the fact that
Pat I'm not a big Speedy guy can I tell
the car oh my God this guy which one the
bench everything
one thing that I know about Uber drivers
yeah right one thing I know about Pat
different to him and I Pat very
influenced by the original Top Gun he
has a Need for Speed straight up we're
in a Bentley in La we hit 150 he goes
let's try it one more time 160. in a
Bentley in LA on the 405 what was that
he was making this [ __ ] up we were going
65 miles an hour ten two who the hell
can go 165 on the 405.
165. you see how Pat suddenly corrected
me yeah 165 by the way 160 are correct
and then you know the poor she just
bought yeah it's sick I made a video
like it was mine we hit like morale
calls me she says congratulations on the
cross and I haven't posted a picture she
says no Vinnie made a video about it
with your car there we go is it because
he's past half a series
in Glendale five like they're all late
for something they all BMWs and it's
just where they going nowhere
for something or it's the old old adage
drive it like you stole it yeah it's as
if everyone in Glendale you know it's
easy place to be a cop in Glendale 100
it's just staying somewhere don't even
work sit there and just give tickets
someone's gonna be speeding yeah so I
guess the question is is this in your
blood like you have to speed have you
ever seen my dad drive listen my dad got
his driver got his driver's license in
the U.S not Iran in 84. from 84 till
today he's not once gotten a ticket one
time cop pulled him over I don't know
for what reason he got upset at the cop
he says how dare you pull me over go
look at my record I followed the law is
what I do the cop felt so bad he let my
dad go yes what does that have to do
with the fact that you go 165 on the
regular balance it out I gotta balance
it out to generation is what you're
saying so listen we got we got a lot of
things to go through we got some some uh
did you guys see Dana White's response
to when people say you need to take some
time away to think about what you did I
did have you seen that have you guys
seen that at all okay first of all we'll
we'll cover cover that and they put
noted marriage counselor Vince back on
the board yeah they did yes McMahon back
on the board yeah apparently he's about
to sell it to Saudi Arabia there's some
rumors about it as if as if Harry needs
any more help selling his book we'll
talk about his book and something's to
do with frostbite penis what is it what
has he got frostbite on what was that
what was that penis Frost snip on his
trudger
right we have seen it that's what it
said apparently he said the book that he
was they had him uh Roger so he could
give spare parts and organs to his older
brother what he said in the book he said
that in the book why would anybody write
that you gotta know yourself he printed
it I will talk about it we'll help him
sell another 100 I think it just shatter
yeah uh and then and then a few other
things by the way you guys see YouTube's
a new one profanity policy have you seen
the new YouTube professional [ __ ] no
profanity policy we'll talk about that
as well and then we got some things to
talk about with uh obviously nothing to
see the Biden documents it's not a big
deal but we'll cover in literally
nothing to see there either yeah we'll
cover that we'll cover what World Bank
Cuts 2023 Global growth projections are
uh with inflation Jerome Powell
confronts his peers and says listen guys
we got to focus on the economy not
climate change we'll talk about that uh
Tom's got some commentary on Microsoft
first puts a billion hours in Chad gbt
now they're thinking about putting
another 10 billion laid off workers are
flooded with fake job offers that's a
Wall Street Journal article stick around
for that one identity Tick Tock CEO
plans to meet European Union Regulators
U.S flight disruptions
Mount after FAA grounding order ends
it's just another reflection of what a
great job Pete buttercich is doing like
you know that's that's one of those
things that's got to be proud of with
his job NBA NBA NBC execs regret giving
Jimmy Fallon 80 million we'll talk about
that we got a few maybe Tate
conversations we'll have Bill Cosby
wants to go on the tour I'm concerned if
he does go on the tour we'll cover that
as well and then Jamil Hill blasts
ex-college Stephen A Smith for taking it
easy on Dana White
and maybe a few other stories but Tom
let's get right into the Jimmy Fallon
story sounds like you got some stuff you
want to talk about there if you want to
go to page nine on what's going on with
Jimmy Fallon by the way do you like
Jimmy Fallon between him and camel do
you like family I love I love captains
very likable okay two things Pat one 100
Fallon they're all obviously they're all
they're all politically biased and they
all do their one like I'll remember all
the videos yeah get the J oh that's all
that stuff
kimmelon just did one this week Kimmel
is the Kim will the most hypocritical
thing about it he's the biggest [ __ ]
talker Trump to everybody man show he he
did blackface he did Shaq all the
biggest models
he didn't do Shaq but uh just
unconscious it's just not funny anymore
it's not funny the hypocrisy is not
funny it's not when he did Karl Malone
some would say that was funny but the
act of you know as if you walk on water
that's my problem that's the part that
you lose credit about here if we're
talking about comedy and late night
Comedians and Fallon and Kimmel and and
and these guys Seth Meyers are missing
one Colbert yeah the the the whole
premise with comedy is being able to
have misdirection oh I didn't see that
one coming that came out of nowhere
that's like a joke he did like the joke
nowhere but when you know
you know the joke starts and where it
ends so Donald Trump's house just got
married like you know where it's ending
yeah so you're just like and as to a
current comedian former comedian it's
like if I'm looking at I don't really
watch a lot of late night but if I do
and I just kind of want to have some
general entertainment and you already
know where the joke is headed it's like
exactly I can't do it by the way we do
have to so this morning we have a tragic
story time like we're trying to have a
good time all of a sudden some guy comes
in getting them giving us an article
emotional article we're like we're all
laughing here until this guy brings this
story it's a kid that's in court you
gotta call this one here crazy citizen
cord he's uh uh you know he's been
liberal parents are getting a divorce a
custody battle do you want to go with
Mom or Dad and they beat him they says
no I don't want to go with my mom or my
dad
terrible situation they both beat him
then the aunt is sitting there do you
want to go with the uh he says no she
beats me twice as much this thing gets I
mean the judge has this grandparents
everybody everybody says so they finally
they're so confused they said where
should we give these kids custody
battles to he chose the Dallas Cowboys
because they don't beat anybody
okay yeah
so let's go by the way just we're on
this topic do you watch any of these
late night shows because Greg gutfeld's
I've very basic fox now this is like the
number one well let me let me first read
this story and we'll have we'll have the
16. so Embassy exec regret paying Jimmy
Fallon 80 million contract extension
as Fox News Greg Gutfeld beats to not
showing ratings The Tonight Show host
Jimmy Fallon is reportedly losing the
raiding War to Fox News a rival Greg
Gutfeld the show is currently drawn in
less than one and a half 1.3 million
viewers compared to gutfel's two and a
half million damn and even less than
Stephen Colbert's Late Late Show on CBS
Fallon signed 80 million out of five
year extension with NBC nearly 19
million months ago but has attracted 30
million subscribers to his YouTube
channel
and uh but this does not drive up ad
rates for the Regular Show there have
been uh there had already been shakeups
in the production staff and Fallon's
contract may not protect him from
further changes NBC may consider buying
out balance contract and replacing him
with a host who can bring in more
viewers
I thought I found this really
interesting today because I I saw Fallon
and then I saw like three other articles
on big payouts going to NFL coaches
getting fired and this guy Matt rule
Carolina Panthers he had gotten a
four-year extension for 40 million
dollars so what happens is at the peak
peek you know NBC or the NFL or another
Sports League to give these guys big
extensions and and then they don't play
out so suddenly Jimmy Fallon basically
goes one and eight to start the year
he's not driving his ad rates up his
YouTube channel isn't helping The
Tonight Show because they're saying wow
he's on social media he's got this and
this and it's helping us and so there's
a real little mini case study here but
the NFL has it right I looked up into
NFL contracts this is very interesting
and it doesn't sound like NBC did this
with Fallon
um we were talking about uh non-compete
yesterday yep right well in the NFL when
you get fired it's called please compete
and let me explain what that means
please compete with me in the NFL Matt
rule under the terms of his agreement
which is with the team but there's also
a um a jurisdictional element with the
NFL Matt rule is going to get that 40
million dollars but from who
in the NFL what they put in contracts if
you're under the age of 60 What's called
the mitigation Clause you have to go out
and find another job you have to and the
NFL has got a whole team of lawyers and
investigators that follow you around and
they're actually making phone calls for
you getting you hooked up with colleges
or other teams you want to know why
let's say Pat you're the owner of the
Carolina Panthers you're on the hook per
the contract for 40 million dollars from
that rule because you're firing him
after a 1-4 start and he lost the locker
room
get out so it's one of the rare firings
in the middle of the Season well you're
on the hook for 40. unless maybe he goes
back to Baylor and gets a five-year 20
million dollar contract
that gets deducted from the 40.
so you know I'm 20. exactly right and so
this happens all over the place in the
NFL Cliff Kingsbury Arizona Cardinals
people really oh you had a 20 million
extension they owe him 20. unless Cliff
gets another job let's stay on this
topic here so it's interesting you're
saying this so in other words if I uh uh
you mean to tell me if somebody right
now called NBC
and said hey if CNN called NBC they
don't have the money to but if CNN
called Embassy and said hey we'll take
that contract away from you just ship
them to us you mean to tell me they
can't take that money away from NBC and
pay that pay that to them typically we
don't know what the fine print Jimmy
Fallon's contract says but typically in
media they pay the money to keep Fallin
on his couch just in case they wouldn't
want him to go to CNN and maybe blow up
and be the old Jimmy Fallon competing
with them wow they don't want that so
they'd rather pay him the money he sits
on his couch figures out what projects
he's going to do what's he's going to
invest in he probably becomes a producer
executive producer starts putting money
into things that he wants to do but the
NFL's got it figured out instead of
non-compete it's please compete go get
another jobs thing tomorrow what a great
uh concept for NFL I mean I understand
what that means go take the money
elsewhere you know go make the money
elsewhere but for great gut feel so so
NBC is free cable isn't it it's free TV
anybody has access
Fox News free cable it's not you have to
pay for it right you have to pay for
cable to watch Greg gutfel so let me get
this straight the one with the free
audience is losing the one that has you
have to pay to watch it 100 buy 2x that
by the way that is absolutely
embarrassing to think about and and can
you help from a successful producer the
most successful producer right now in
all of the universe of cable and
television is Greg Gutfeld he created
the five he owns a big chunk of that
show he's the most successful in the
biggest viewership he's King right now
and and going off of what Adam said too
uh Pat you know why
the camel is getting camels getting to
see if he's beating both of them come on
and when people say why you know why
Gutfeld is so is out there Tom when you
watch them on that college that's who he
is there and when he walks into your
house or your partying he's that same
guy when you watch CNN and [ __ ] you you
think like would you want to be at a
party 30 and see any of these anchors
from lemon or whatever Cuomo's in there
they're they have an agenda about people
like real [ __ ] you know why Tucker's up
there because Tucker is the same off as
he is on CNN and all these networks bro
they're not that's why these guys are
killing it and they're baffled by CNN
and all these uh left-wing political
people are going down bro look at this
Adam yeah well I I just let's let's just
kind of go back a second okay just think
about where we're at in America right
now this actually here we go here we are
guys Kumbaya not too long ago 40 years
ago 40 years ago the beginning of our
lifetime there was one king of late
night his name was Johnny Carson best
Johnny and that it was like the Walter
Cronkite for news in the 60s what have
you Johnny Carson in the 70s 80s there
was like if you made it onto Carson as a
comedian as a performer that's it done
you're now famous remember comedians
would do their four minute bit and if
they got invited to the couch yeah it
was like you were amazing I mean Tom
when you made it to the couch that one
time in 1976 when you started off in
comedy it was like the groundbreaking
that was the business
how you made it here thank God the biz
docs here they fired up but now we're
we're at a point in America now where
there's so much competition every single
one of these then it went from from
Carson and went like no one Letterman
that was two guys right now you have uh
in the rankings of order you have
Colbert Fallon Kimmel Seth Meyers Coco
and yeah who's Coco Conan O'Brien oh
Corner Brian was the best was the best
but now he has it's so saturated and
they're all kind of cannibalizing each
other each of these shows like if you
add up their numbers Colbert's at 2.1
million uh Fallon's at 1.3 Kimball's a
little over a million so you're talking
four and a half Collective on the big
three is beating Kimmel and Fallon gut
field is at 2.3 million so this is what
I'm this is like the five is the number
one hey Tom Tim buddy we'll get right
back to you thank you uh can I make my
point yeah make it
like the Cisco and Ebert over here but
here's the deal
gutfelt I watched it last night
ironically he's not a comedian no he's
not funny no he's not even that
entertaining he is himself exactly okay
he's not a stand-up comedian not at all
he's entertaining he's got opinions
that's great but when you have three
this is kind of what I was saying before
when you already know where the joke is
going and you have three Colbert uh
camel Fallon and it just kind of Fallon
at one point was amazing with the roots
when it first started yeah doing the
music and the carpool karaoke is James
Corden still doing his show by the way I
haven't seen that but he's trying to get
into that restaurant essentially this is
where I'm going with this
um Gutfeld has Blue Ocean strategy
written all over him everyone's going
this way let's just go this way and
let's just stay true to ourselves I'm
not shocked
that he's the number one king of late
night but it's not because he's super
super amazingly talented and hilarious
and has awesome stuff no it's just that
it's the same old [ __ ] over here on the
left and he's just going a different
direction you know what it got really
worse I said it I've said this before
kovid killed comedy for all those people
because as soon as you start dancing and
going okay jab yourself with it bye I'm
done I'm done was it coveted or was it
Trump because no Trump started it no
you're 100 but Kobe killed it because
when they did when they had needles on
whatever like what the f what was it
that was Colbert that made me go blind
yeah look at this [ __ ] look yeah put a
needle in there that's just propaganda
but that's what I'm saying that's where
you know it was going thank you do you
remember when um
uh Jon Stewart went on Colbert and they
talked about China how uncomfortable how
uncomfortable was Colbert do you
remember that oh Jon Stewart's like Jon
Stewart who is as liberal yes
section of liberal ideas as it gets Bill
Maher John Stewart and he's like so how
about that lab leak yeah Colbert was
like no okay definitely came from about
oh my God
it was that story with the like the
unkept beard and the longer hair and
it's like Jon Stewart's been in the tool
shed behind his house for two years
look at the body language
and they're best friends by the 100 so
it just it's I don't know it's
awkward you guys said a lot you made a
very good point going back only one
option now there's a lot of options the
numbers you gave gut filled beating
camel and Fallon at the same time I do
have a recommendation for NBC there's a
guy you can get for pro I can negotiate
a good price for you guys his name is
Marcelo Hernandez he's on SNL guarantee
you keep your eyes on him one of those
two's gonna lose him either NBC's gonna
pick him up or the other guy's gonna
pick him up that guy's going I would
watch that show I would watch that show
all day that's where you're going no I
like that guy a lot he's a talent you
know what it is here's one of the
biggest uh things to uh uh that that
happens to everybody you have to be
aware of you have to be aware of so you
go into the NBA first time you're going
to the NBA you play against the great
ones and you say oh my God I'm on the
same floor with freaking Kobe Jordan oh
my God I can't believe I have to guard
Jordan tonight imagine you've just gone
to the NBA
you're guarding Michael Jordan you're
Byron or Russell Brian Russell and
you're guarding Michael Jordan or
Dominique's well Dominic's brother
Gerald Wilkins the Jordan stuff yes New
York oh you know so man so for what how
was your day today dude I can't even
believe dog you know when he was doing
the turn he made that one shot I didn't
even know how to block it I tried I got
close but this guy's there's a reason
why they come and you're having this
conversation it's a childlike
conversation right so you know you're a
comedian you get your first shot like
Marcelo called the other day Zoom yeah
you won't believe this I'm this and then
he picks me up Chappelle calls this and
then we drive up and then in front of
this and I cannot believe it and I'm at
Madison Square Garden I'm like I'm
watching this guy he could have gone 30
more minutes I would have listened to
him because I'm watching a kid's dream
become a reality it's a beautiful moment
to witness man when it becomes a reality
right it's when you win in business it's
when you you know in in so many
different ways when you become a parent
the first time in your emotion on all
this and then comes 10 years later
and then you become arrogant ungrateful
you lose perspective and then you're no
longer that likable
now your interview is like yeah we lost
in the playoffs so what I'm still making
18 million a year I'm gonna go to my
beautiful house I'm gonna go do this
LeBron yeah that's annoying if you go
watch Jimmy Fallon's uh
audition I think you told me about it I
mean you watch this guy you're like man
you want to see this guy win right
Talent so sometimes somebody I was
talking to a guy yesterday who's in in
deep trouble and no it's not Andrew Tate
although he's also in trouble but I'm
talking to this other guy
and I was saying to him that guy's going
in this Trail of the Fallon camel Trail
where you're becoming annoying and
you're becoming too arrogant I'm like
who's who's he talking to that can kind
of give him a different perspective
because sometimes when you're in the
chemical position or a Fallon position
you're in a web
and you're stuck and you no one's
telling you what you need to hear to
Pivot to One Direction Nobody is
everybody around you is just telling the
same same same same same same same
so you just keep going then all of a
sudden you become this arrogant guy that
we have to fire and replace you with
somebody else that's a little bit more
excited to be there that can stay child
like this is why the people who win long
term stay childlike the longest Elon
Musk is still childlike whoever stays
childlike not childish childlike the
longest wins this morning you know we're
sitting here saying what you're saying
about Tom you know what Phil I got from
Tom this morning childlike
being childlike has nothing to do with
your age it has to do with a mindset to
stay fresh especially when your job is
to entertain if your job is to make
deals who gives a [ __ ] but if your job
is to entertain you best stay childlike
and grit Gutfeld to me yeah every time I
see him the guy's childlike do you watch
gut felt any of you guys I've seen them
I've seen his Clips I watch him on
YouTube I like his monologues you can
tell you know what I like about his
monologues he'll say a joke it's like
yeah that was not a good one let me rip
this one out well you know what that was
good okay you guys like that one it's a
very he has got a relationships
different too he's in front of a live
audience yeah there's people there which
adds another element to it which I like
I just I want to know like if you're the
CBS
showrunner the executive if you're doing
NBC ABC and at e it was just circle back
2016-27 it's so easy just to start
[ __ ] on Trump it's such a weird time
in America yeah of course you are and
they believe me they would mess with
Obama nowhere near Trump I mean not even
close at what point does the showrunner
or the producer say Hey listen we've
officially lost half our audience
why don't we be the ones to like bring
this back in just a little let's beat
let's say you're you're because because
Fallon doesn't go over the top like Kemo
or Colbert so I'm just wondering are
they they must see these numbers and
they must be like what the [ __ ] are we
doing I think it's laziness too so I'm
not to cut you off I think it's laziness
as as a production team truck like why
talk about anything else just trump it
up but I I like what you said I I
wouldn't want all it took is one of them
to go guys let everybody talk about
Trump because that's all everybody's
talking about let's just be creative
let's go talk about other [ __ ] not just
this guy and like I've said this before
CNN the only way because CNN's losing
money left and right the only way
they're gonna end Center and Center is
if I'm telling right now Trump because
the Santa's I don't know if it's gonna
help them if Trump wins the election
CNN's going to be right back on top
because that's all they're going to do
that's all they're going to talk about I
think DeSantis is going to hurt
everybody's ratings because there's
nothing nothing about them yeah
you good Christian wholesome man let's
hear from our community I think you I
think
you get to the get to the core of it
you're asking is there a showrunner I
think they all live in a bubble they're
living in a bubble which orange man bad
conservative slap home anti-vaxxers or
unpatriotic and their loons or their
Fringe their right-wing Fringe when you
do that you are ignoring the mass of the
audience and I think there was a day
where that was cared about but I think
media in the bubble I honestly don't
think those late night I think they are
and to a large degree they're reading
talking points and it is kind of
propagandist I remember
Letterman's first show on CBS after the
deals were done the big thing they
opened the Ed Sullivan Theater in New
York Letterman does his first show he's
doing his opening monologue and
Letterman had this real nostalgic sense
about NBC because NBC gave him a shot he
was almost the successor to Johnny
Carson he ends up on the after Johnny
Carson saw it and it was amazing he
cracks these two jokes and then his
buddy Tom Brokaw NBC news guy cameos
walks into the CBS Studio takes the big
cue cards and says Dave I'm really
disappointed those last two jokes were
the intellectual property of NBC I'm
taking him down the street and he walks
off the stage and Letterman looks at the
cameras says and this was the shot for
Warren Littlefield at NBC he says that's
odd I didn't think you could use
intellectual property and NBC in the
same sentence oh wow and it was but it
was funny and it was truly funny and you
looked at the balance and you looked at
what Lena was doing and what Letterman
was doing and it wasn't political slap
on parade and I think they've lost that
I think now media is in a bubble and
they've lost it I think something that
you said that I want to highlight and
and go deeper on is the writers so who
are the writers Conan O'Brien was that
writer by the way yeah at one point
Letterman yep um but who are the writers
well if you talk about you know ten to
one liberal professors to conservative
professors at school so if you go to
school or if you're in the media
entertainment writing uh performing
liberal arts liberal arts part of the
school you tend to be more liberal so
now
just using basic numbers let's say
there's 10 applicants and nine of them
lean liberal right yeah I mean you did
comedy how many are more conservative
versus liberal in comedy comedy is a lot
more 80 90 yes yeah so that's the
candidates that that's the pool of
talent so that's what they're gonna
start writing to so I mean who's doing
all the writing the Jews I mean they're
doing it no it's it's typically more
liberal uh minded people and that's
who's writing these jokes so it I think
you're absolutely spot on it's not let's
go to the reading talking points 100
let's go to the next story let's go to
the next story with Microsoft GPT Tom uh
they originally put a billion into it
now they're going to 10 billion let's
read this article here that we have so
Microsoft reportedly plans to invest 10
billion dollars of creative of a buzzy
AI tool chat gbt this is an NBC NBC news
story
um a uh startup behind the popular AI
tool Chad gbt as part of a funding
ground that would value or open AI 29
billion dollars according to a report
the deal would give Microsoft a 75 share
of open AI profits until it recoups its
investment after which the company would
assume a 49 stake on in open air damn
like 49
the report state that the deal has not
been finalized yet and that the plan was
to close the deal by the end of 2022
open AI gbt is natural language
processing model which can generate next
that appears to be written by a human it
is widely used to be developing code and
writing essays this spent on chat gbt
may help Microsoft in its web search
efforts Tom
Microsoft is a genius
um and you you look back
Once Upon a Time Apple was struggling
and Steve Jobs calls Bill Gates and says
listen Apple's going to go bankrupt but
we need your help uh we need and Gates
came up with 150 million dollars and it
was on the cover of Time Magazine Steve
Jobs on the phone that says thank you
Bill the world is a better place because
apple and Microsoft can coexist
Microsoft sold that a couple years later
for 550 million dollars had they held
that until Apple Peak last February you
know what that would have been worth
122 billion dollars if they would have
held it if they would have held it yeah
and by the way they thought they had
made Bank hey we gave Apple 150 we just
got 550 back half a billion Wahoo
Microsoft is really smart about this
stuff and you notice they're holding it
at 49 and by the way they've already
invested a billion in this they know
what they're doing
um and they're on top of it and they're
going to make money on this remember
um do you remember something called
Encarta
it's funny do you know what that is in
Carta and Carter was a CD it's like a
little DVD CD and it was an unbelievable
dictionary it was like four times the
content of the set of world book
encyclopedias if anybody remembers what
those were and
that was what Microsoft believed was
there it is
1995 was going was an information
resource for your computer and remember
Microsoft said you know this internet
thing is probably going to come and go
because they saw it like prodigy or AOL
so they were wrong about that since that
moment Microsoft has not been wrong
these guys are going to make money on
this and this is a really smart move and
you go back and look at what they did
with apple they're a king maker they
think open AI has what it takes to be a
trillion dollar company
I mean another trillion dollar company
do you think it has a shadow being a
trillion dollar company in 10 years
absolutely okay so that's a half a
billion dollar valuation added to
Microsoft yeah at least well I mean 449
is is you're talking about you mean half
a trillion half a trillion what did I
say and you said a half half a billion
half a billion is nothing it's a half a
trillion dollars yeah this is another
500 not a trillion dollars yeah 500
billion dollars added to valuation
gotcha yeah that's another half a
billion on the Microsoft stock price I
am surprised others are not going in
this every once in a while you get some
kind of a company that comes along like
this that you can you're seeing the
results of what it's capable of doing
we're not talking about FTX you know
we're talking about you can sit there
you know what the biggest complaint is
yesterday I posted a video about what is
Chad gbt and who's behind it you know
what's the most common tweet I got back
from people here's the most common
response stop talking about Chad gbt I
use it daily and every time you guys
talk about it the website
[Laughter]
okay I want to watch that because here's
the question I have yeah generally
sometimes it's better to ask questions I
mean I don't know much about this why
are people using it because my
assumption at least initially is hey I'm
a 20 year old college kid time to write
that essay uh thanks chat gbt so why why
are people using like what are they
using it for I'm not doubting why
someone would use it Adam what are the
reasons they're using ready for this
then this is off school right right now
I could say go on it right now yeah
right and say this I need a I need a
sketch shot Friday I need some ideas I
just put in their little search thing
come up with 50 sketch ideas
is at capacity right now we can't even
get in that's how many people are trying
to get off yeah that's how many college
kids are trying to get through essays
he's talking it's basically doing all
the work for you so you don't have to
it's basically it's the robot is doing
all the work and I mean then you could
take it's it's I don't know bro so so
writing papers
so for example I'll give you I'll give
you I'll give you an idea so let's just
say you're about to interview uh Elon
Musk or you're about to interact about
that it's coming up you're about to
interview whoever let's just say you're
interviewing somebody you're looking
forward to you say uh give me 10
questions no one no one's ever asked
Elon Musk in an interview it'll give you
more questions and make it original too
okay hey give me it can now write code
oh my God it can write code it can make
rap songs it can make real it can make I
mean it's the capability and by the way
this is 1.0 yeah it's not 2.0 3.0 5.0
not at all this is 1.0 go ahead Tom
when I say
I'll ask one quick question
the usage of this thing is so spread
wide it is like the internet for AI if
you think of it that way it's that big
when do you think they will have on a
trailing one month 12 month basis a
billion dollars in Revenue
and I'll and I'll help you out your
answer will be in in months wow how many
months until they will have a trailing
billion dollars six months what are the
revenue sources is it advertising
because is this open to the public how
do you how do they make money usage is
the answer the answer is 17 months
before the end of 2024 they will be
running a billion dollar Revenue company
not valuation because a VC thought oh
I'll give you your unicorn valuation
Revenue okay and gpt4 there there we go
gpt4 there it is is is coming and that's
just going to accelerate it further and
GPT by the way feel is putting a billion
dollars on here the planetary guys are
they public yet huh palantir guys
palantir yeah sorry sorry how are they
driving revenue is it all oh it's going
to be 7.99 a week I believe it's going
to be seven can you look to see how much
it's going to be perfect you have to pay
for do you use it uh this this it's a
plug-in license that's basically the the
way it works plug into what whatever you
want what are you plugging into you can
plug it into
a term paper website and so you and I
run a term paper website people can go
and build term paper we pay a plug-in
licensing fee every time it's used so
there's a subscription model built into
it correct and but is that how they're
going to make the majority of their of
their revenue or is it going to be spot
like sponsors advertising that kind of
stuff ad Revenue I I think it's D all of
the above and because like right now
Adam you can go in and it'll print
something that's only like two or three
pages for you or like a page you have to
pay to get the
November November November wow it
launched in six it's the fastest ever to
get to a million users how do you think
Rob got all this you think Rob did this
yeah Rob didn't do that Rob didn't even
do it by the way by the way give me a
podcast out here's what people don't
even know this is why Greg gut Fields
beating everything that's it that's
who's right his monologue writers you
just figured it out yeah that's a comedy
that's a glorious ladies and gentlemen
all right let's get to the next story
here we figured if let's if you can get
into chat gbt put a nickel in it you're
gonna make some money on it Jerome
Powell nickel Jerome Powell warns
Federal Reserve should not take climate
change uh should not tackle climate
change and social issues as he slaps
down woke colleagues ooh ooh that's not
good to do that uh in that space all
right let's see what he says here
uh what page are we on it's supposed to
be seven there you go okay Federer is a
chair Jerome Powell cautioned that the
FED must resist the temptation to tackle
social issues such as climate change
saying that taking on new goals such as
climate or social policy without a clear
statutory mandate would undermine the
case for the fed's independence Powell
emphasized that the fed's regulatory
Powers give it a narrow role to ensure
financial institutions appropriately
manage the risks they face from climate
change but it should not be a climate
policy maker he also stated that
decisions about policies to directly
address climate change should be made by
the elected branches of the government
and must uh reflect the Public's will as
expressed through elections what are
your thoughts by the way tomorrow Vivek
who's going to be on he wrote the book
awoke and couple other books on this
topic one other book on this topic he'll
be here ESG so so what Tom is the is
what he's really saying is ESG can apply
to corporations but not to the Federal
Reserve let us do our part don't judge
us with our ESG score or is he just
saying let's not get the two confused
let's run a business here yeah I think
we just talk about his independence he's
saying listen without a clear mandate
you're going to undermine our
independence we're supposed to
independently look all over the economy
all over legislation and everything and
saying where should interest rates
discount rates and these other things be
we're supposed to be independent on that
now you're saying that rates and other
things would move and Bank overnight
banking rates would would change if they
want to penalize institutions or
Industries no I I I'm with Powell here
it's like all right I know everybody
wants to do and by the way
World economic Forum tomorrow they're
getting together in Davos you know it's
coming up
listen most of the climate change saying
is income redistribution if you take a
look what's really going on there and
all he's saying is hey we're supposed to
be independent
fueling the economy with everything
that's in that leave us alone and do
this because unless there's a mandate to
do this you elected guys do it you
program guys do it you tax guys do it
and I think that's all he's saying and I
think he's right I just want to say one
thing about Jerome Powell and just to
I'm gonna I'm gonna reiterate this and
reiterate this a drone pal is the most
important person in America today it's
not Trump it's not Biden it's not Elon
Musk it's not this person that like
Jerome Powell as Jerome Powell goes the
Country goes at this point everything
that's going on with inflation and money
Printing and stimulus checks and
everything I mean is there is there is
there a person even on Jerome Powell's
level right now including the president
United States is anybody even touching
Jerome Powell's status as far as the
most important American in the world
right now anybody he's up there he's up
there with the amount of influence that
he has but what's your point with
climate change I don't know nothing
about college it's just the fact that
that's the stance that he's taking is is
a very very yeah but this is about
climate change we know he's the most
powerful but most people but most people
don't know that that's what I'm saying
but I understand that so for for a guy
this powerful to say what he says about
climate change what's he saying to his
peers you know what it's like it's kind
of like when Jon Stewart went to his
buddy and he says so what do you think
about the fact that the virus was leaked
from Wuhan it was not a bat no it's not
a bad what's the last time you saw about
so so Jerome Powell is essentially
calling out his peers the same way Bill
Maher is calling out his own side it's
the same way Stephen A Smith is calling
at his own side it is a very tough
position to be in because when you get
invited to those parties which Jerome
Powell is going to be at
people are going to go up to them and
they're going to say why would you make
those kind of comments you know how much
progress we were making with climate
change and you say something like that
and you know the media on the opposite
side our enemy is going to pick it up we
have to stay United you can't say
something like that so for a guy like
that to say that
you know it it just comes across as
there is at least somebody with logic
that is thinking the way that Jerome
Powell is thinking and by the way don't
forget who nominated Jerome Powell it
was Trump Biden kept him yeah so you
hear you have someone that's
David Rubenstein our good friend yeah
seven years wow yeah he worked for David
rubinson so yeah and he's saying this on
the eve of Davos which is coming up over
the next seven that's what I'm saying
for him to say that that with the timing
of it I think he's given the other fed
Board of Governors also air cover he's
given them air cover so from the top
he's saying we're not going to get
involved in this and doing it so he
would be giving someone like let's say
I'm on the board in St Louis the FED in
St Louis he's giving me some air cover
because the boss is saying hey we're
going to worry about fiscal policy and
you get elected officials everybody else
they're flying your
um highly pollutant private jets into
Davos at this very moment you guys can
talk about global warming right and Tom
think of just he's given me air cover
yeah you you'll know this I mean what is
the purpose of the FED it's there to you
know stamp down inflation uh price of
goods unemployment keep the uh the money
supply it has nothing to do with social
issues or
ESG or anything like that so that just
that just do your job and that's his job
independently turn the knobs that help
the economy for everyone right so
respect to to Powell good to see he's
coming out and saying these type of
things is what I'm saying because his
voice carries we need more of this okay
so here's another story as white collar
layoffs rise Blue Collar resilience
faces test in 2023 what it's a Wall
Street Journal story no Paige so uh page
six bottom White Collar layoffs are
starting to rise and it's uncertain if
this trend will spread the blue collar
industries as interest rates increase
according to labor department data
average layoffs and finance and
insurance uh uh insurance industry went
from September to November nearly
doubled from a year earlier job cuts and
real estate leasing brokerage and
information also increased by 20 and 14
over the same period however
manufacturers Leisure and hospitality
and Retail sectors laid off fewer
workers in the three months through
November compared to a year ago Blue
Collar sectors are less affected by
interest rates but if demand softens
they might hesitate to fight higher
Frontline workers they struggle to hire
and retain during the pandemic Tom is
there anything to this story we need to
be paying attention to yes there is oh
we were talking yesterday on the podcast
no day before I said in the podcast we
talked about all the stats and the
credit card and you talked about it's
just a matter of time it's a ticking
bomb you're just kicking the can down
the road
first of all we have to remember
things in America are mostly
manufactured in China and offshore but
the manufacturing we do have in America
if those consumers slow down blue I so I
agree with the headline Blue Collar
resilience faces a test and the
resilience is going to be the resilience
in consumer spending and whether they're
buying things that are made here in
America and if they're not it's a lot of
those blue collar folks are going to
have um some Challengers there's layoffs
going all over the place you saw Google
laid off 15 and three different uh
divisions CFO roof really really sharp
she's out there uh what Google calls
other bets laying off laying off laying
off and that's all because of demand and
she's saying it's demand base they're
not seeing the demand for the other bets
at Google's making so if credit cards
and other things start reducing demand
for physical things because Google is
I.T then yeah I think Blue Collar
halfway through this year if it's a real
recession I think we should be seeing
some of that and I don't look forward to
it it's going to hurt core America I'll
add to that Tom you know likes to give
them more macro perspective I'll give
more the micro perspective how that
affects you as your life well I'm going
to channel my inner Warren Buffett you
know the one way to be Recession Proof
or inflation proof is to be the best at
your job so we talked about which
teachers should get raises and which
teachers should be fired and you think
that you should fire the bottom ten
twenty percent there's no question about
it no question yeah so if you suck at
your job
you're probably gonna get fired but if
you're great at your job you're probably
going to keep your job you're probably
going to get a raise and God forbid your
company has layoffs this is going to be
a job waiting for you so at the end of
the day this comes down to personal
responsibility personal accountability
personal finance if you're the [ __ ] at
your job not shitty at your job you're
gonna have a job forever yeah if you
suck good riddance get on that Snapchat
Ai and start using the [ __ ] on it right
now exactly right term papers for people
right be the local genius this is
wonderful thank you but I think also
there's something what Adam said is you
know what maybe take it easy on
discretionary spending first half of the
year maybe they can't save that money
yeah save that money save extra few
dollars and see how this is gonna play
out you know you you see those Maps
those they call them the spaghetti maps
with all the possible tracks of a
hurricane that's coming toward Florida
or the Gulf Coast right here in America
you should be thinking of that like you
don't know where it's going to hit but
at some point this year there's going to
be a storm what do you do make sure
you've got your coat make sure you've
kind of ease up on the discretionary
spending a little bit and just and just
be ready for whatever whatever it brings
and if it's an easy year buy yourself a
little extra at the holidays yeah I'm
thinking of right now I'm sorry I'm
going remember there was a hurricane
coming to hit like Florida and then
there was like spaghetti maps and then
Trump like Drew in like marker or cran
like it could also go here yeah it's
like uh Trump
yeah I remember this he completely just
like I hope everybody hurt Adam's point
in my follow-up yeah maybe be prudent
this year yeah look out for yourself and
then if the year doesn't turn out that
bad get yourself a little something nice
ultimately what I'm saying is if there's
a wall there you know just find a way to
get over the wall and just get around
that wall but it's so funny draw
yourself an extra little spaghetti cone
over there all right Let's do let's do
another store here with Bill Cosby and
then I want to go into the uh
Declassified documents uh with uh
President Biden if you want to go to
page 10
um if we go to page 10 here by the way
what we may do is to have the audience
follow with us we may give the PDF for
people to be able to follow with us as
well let's be smart something about so
to be thinking about okay so Bill Cosby
victims slam his plan to tour this year
victims of Bill Cosby have expressed
their anger at the comedian's plan for
comeback tour after sexual assault
conviction was overturned in 2021.
Andrew constant who whose testimony
played a crucial your rolling Cosby's
2018 conviction said that if anybody
deserves a comeback comeback tour it's
the woman he traumatized and abused
other victims echoed the similar
sentiments expressing their belief that
Cosby's reputation is damaged Beyond
repair and that he will continue to face
protests and negative reactions from
audiences Cosby has been accused of
sexual assaults by around 45 women and
spent three years in prison for the
crime so good idea bad idea I mean all I
think about is that first show if if you
if I'm willing to bet most people would
go to the show just to see who's showing
up 100 to see how they're going to react
for this guy having the audacity to do
this so is he doing it for money I don't
think so I think he's got money is he
doing it because he wants to go set the
record straight bad way of doing it what
do you think about the idea of women
going on the score I mean I think the
thing about how old is he he's fallen
apart one of his eyes stop for 80
something years old dude he how old is
Bill I'm gonna say 85 what 85 85 years
old right Pat either he just doesn't
want to be home he's hours from being an
organ donor yeah there's two way either
he just not does not want to be home
with you know he doesn't want to deal
with that or he's genuinely loves comedy
which I heard I I watched the comedian
which is an old thing with Jerry
Seinfeld and uh orney Adams and they
went to go see uh Bill Cosby in the
theater day shows packed sold out and he
would do Rob I think two and a half
hours and just sit there and people come
I think he's doing it him personally
he's doing it because he just bro he's a
comedian and he's been locked up and
he's been away think about what his
first joke is going to be think about
the first thing that's going to come out
of his room so I just flew in from
Dallas
from jail who's gonna sell the tickets
to this thing this is this is the put
you to sleep tour sponsored by roofie
you know I mean what are what are we
that's a sponsor I'm this is a very very
weird situation and there's another
comedian that just had a a YouTube video
come out about him I'm not going to say
any names
by the way I started dancing some
canceling some dates from this other
comedian that had a a documentary come
out about him that's it's not goodbye
maybe people if you have fans some
people some fans don't care it'd be
interesting Tom brought up a good point
Who's Gonna sell tickets to this like
Andrew Tate got de-platformed for
misogynistic comments yeah from PayPal
from stripe he couldn't actually receive
income but this guy was convicted of
raping women he's gonna go out on tour
is Ticketmaster going to be the one
that's gonna sell those tickets we got
the venue too I mean and hotels you know
um Native Americans running the regional
casinos that are very very popular
Choctaw Casino and things like that
which one of those is going to put their
brand up Pat and allow to put Bill
Cosby's name on the big sign in front of
their brand MGM presents Bill Cosby yeah
I I don't know I don't see any major
brands distancing them uh acknowledging
him I wanted to promote this guy I just
don't see it who's gonna put their name
on a an 85 year old guy you're going to
attach your Your Wagon to this guy yeah
at the tail end of his career when he's
trying to like clean up his legacy
you're like all right and I guarantee
you HBO now presents Bill Cosby hell no
I will guarantee you guys too it'll sell
out like that watch oh Who the hell's
going You're Gonna dude there's a demand
I don't I don't understand like a train
wreck everyone was uh no no I don't
think it's gonna it's like the same
reason people again cannot wait to go
watch Chris Rock's show the first time
he's gonna talk about what he's going to
talk about you know you guys see Eddie
Murphy speech this week when he won and
he says Hey 46 years I've been an actor
I've been in the entertainment business
46 years 41 years acting this the first
time I'm winning this and he says
there's three things I learned in my
career your mind your own business pay
your own taxes and keep Will Smith's
wife out of here
yeah it was brilliant
I don't know what he won but he won for
this one show and very very uh
interesting different kind of an Eddie
Murphy in nowadays but but for me with
this it's more about him why is he doing
it at 85 okay uh why would you do it
what's your motive of wanting to do it
you really think people gonna
45 women they're saying one or two or
three you're talking about 45 of them
yeah okay you think that's people gonna
be like oh you're forgiven we'll move on
I don't think so I don't know but he
can't leave his think about it he can't
leave his house because wherever he goes
there's gonna be so maybe that's that's
his only literally Outlet to just get
the hell out and sit in a room where
people like him so he could tell I mean
what are you gonna talk about I don't
even get it he's got a lot to talk about
man prison three years of prison I think
he's just trying to clean up his legacy
uh that's uncleanable four or five women
well okay that we know can I can I ask
the the the panel some questions I want
to give you some names you tell me the
likelihood that they're guilty or not
God you just do this I'll be on my
opinion okay oh J guilty 100 100 so OJ
killed two people straight up and he's
walking around he lost looking for The
Killers he wrote he wrote he tried to
release a book that said I didn't do it
but if I did this is only because I
loved her very much remember that yeah
you're at 100 OJ okay okay
so so Cosby
100 he's drunken girls
okay Harvey Weinstein guilty guilty he
did all this right uh Mrs Weinstein I
don't I'm kind of on the I don't know 50
50. 50 50. I don't know but back to
Cosby we're on agreeance that OJ Cosby
and Weinstein are guilty AF yeah all
right I'm just putting that out there
that we are acknowledging the fact that
they are guilty 100 meanwhile OJ's still
out there yeah killing it yeah so we'll
see what this guy calls me has going on
but it is if I think Tom had nailed it
what
uh Revenue I'm sorry what um
location sponsor Ticketmaster
any any of those there's a big
difference conglomerates they're going
to promote big difference between those
three and Tate those three were found
guilty convicted Tate's still going
through so you can't even put him in
that category maybe you could put
Michael Jackson in that category maybe
you can put Kevin Spacey on the category
he can't put some people that are going
through around that's why I give down I
don't put tape in that category and I
also look at it but trust in Romanian
courts yeah yeah but go going through
this going through this with uh uh with
uh Bill Cosby
I I don't know I'm more I'm more talking
about you're literally not going to win
people over with this you're not your
legacy you know Dana White you know the
video came out TMZ and his wife hits him
and he slaps her back and then
the next day he's on TMZ he says for 15
years or for 20 years I've been telling
Fighters never Lay Your Hands on a girl
never lay hands on and here I'm the
idiot sitting here having to explain
myself with TMZ
he's in a press conference and they're
asking him I don't know if you can find
a word I don't know if we can play the
video we can't play the video but his
words he says what do you want me to do
okay let's talk about it Rob if you want
to turn off your mic what do you want
what do you want to do you want me to
you want me to uh uh you want me to uh
take time off to think about this of my
decision I already know it was a bad
decision yeah what do you want me to do
you want me to take a moment and reflect
reflect for what you want me to take
time off this he says what about if in
2016 what he's trying to say is when the
company sold I could have taken the time
off I didn't need to do this anymore I
could have been done okay what should
the repercussions be I take 30 days off
how does that hurt me I told you guys as
we were going through covid-19 pandemic
covet could last 10 years and I could
sit it out it's much like covet actually
me leaving hurts the company hurts my
employees hurts the fighters doesn't
hurt me I could have left in 2016 when
the company was acquired by Endeavor do
I need to reflect I've been against this
I've owned I'm telling you that I'm
wrong here's my punishment I have to
walk around for however long I live
that's the point I wanted to make what
he said here here's my punishment I have
to walk around for however long I live
and this is how I'm labeled now my other
punishment is that I'm sure a lot of
people whether it be in the media
Fighters friends acquaintances who had
respect for me might not have that
respect for me now there's a lot of
things I have to deal with for the rest
of my life that's way more punishment
than what I take a 30 or 60 day absence
of what he just said by the way when
he's talking if you've not seen this
clip you can tell he's getting choked up
but he's not going to show his emotions
because you can tell he knows he messed
up right
but the angle He took is
listen this is for me forever how long
do you think this is going to stay with
Dana forever forever how long do you
think it's going to stay with uh um
with uh with uh uh uh Cosby forever do
you think he can do anything no that
he'll be forgiven for no no no this is
permanent okay if I were to ask you
right now watch this I'm gonna give you
names tell me what's going to be with
them till their deathbed you ready
Clinton
if you say him boom if you can go to
Marlon Brando
uh Marlon Brando Godfather no he's just
he was a prick on set and James Dean
because it's a whole different story
right Playboy that's a completely
different story now if you don't know
the story go look up the story between
James Dean and Marlon Brando if I give
you Kevin Spacey if I give you Mike if I
give you any president I give you Bush
second one what are you gonna think 911.
do you if I give you John F Kennedy
what's the first time I come Fascination
what else does it come to mind what else
comes to Vietnam Marilyn Monroe what
else comes one month
there are certain things that we as
human beings are going to do that's
permanent and there's nothing you can do
about it yeah and trying to convince
everybody how great of a human being you
are it's not helping and it really sucks
just the way you live yeah you screwed
up yeah and you got to live with it it
just sucks all that you could do you
could be the greatest anything whatever
it takes one one little like like oh
like like that joke I think I told you
guys that joke that builds a thousand
Bridges
he's in the ball one goat yeah he's yeah
that's the joke he's like he's in the
bar and the guy's like why the long
faces like you see that you know let him
tell the joke why are you taking the
show 12 times on the podcast go ahead I
never said the joke it's over but anyway
my point being you're talking about
[ __ ] I'm saying no I'm what I'm saying
is you could do anything in this life
like Bill Clinton great really really
good president right doing to him what
Tom is doing to you
under these positions
it takes one you oh you could do
whatever it's one goat one goal or one
cigar or one thing about it and then
that's your legacy but I do like I
respect Manning up right off the bat and
not letting the system say that's why
this is what we're doing is a g bro
Dana man's up handles it and then says
what do you want me to do yeah take 30
days off take 60 days off take what what
do you want me to do here you're right
versus you know you hear certain people
like well let me tell you I'm this and
let me tell you it's the Matrix let me
tell you it's this no man just like what
position do you want to take this is
sounding like no victim on the way this
guy handled it Dana the way he is
handling this
sounds like a if'd up I'm not a victim
don't feel bad for me my life's gonna
suck because of this decision that I
made my kids are always in arguments
because well you did this Dad
how can you tell me you're being a
hypocrite he's gonna he knows this this
is permanent FYI what what this does is
it this isn't about you know you know
how they share success there's levels to
success so let's talk about levels to
success what are levels of success okay
levels of success as you were a high
school freaking Superstar
[ __ ] you got records in your high school
damn it when you go back it's like Al
Bundy you know my records
man you guys should go back and look at
my records in high school when I play
basketball my uh the only stats you'll
see with records with me is elbows the
other day my coach called me from uh he
called me we're having a conversation
together with this guy from New Century
City basketball association when I was
playing at Echo Park he says do you
remember when we lost by 100 points I
said do I remember my dad skipped the
trophy since 14 years old of course I
remember it's the only Sports trophy I
got I wasn't an athlete like the two of
you guys by the way just so you know
these two guys were Superstars you go
out with Vinnie Vinnie throws the ball
and the ball just keeps it's still
traveling by the way it makes it look
like there's nothing Adam throws the
ball it's like he woke up no prom right
but no you know there's levels to sports
level sharpness the elbows in all of
them there's levels to Fighters he one
guy hey do you see that guy was a great
fighter he punched one guy in the face
he fell for the rest of his life he's a
great fighter one punch okay that guy's
a great Gambler that guy's this there's
levels to success and there's levels to
F ups there's levels to F UPS meaning
Cosby is f up it's a level on its own
Michael Jackson's f up it's pretty up
there OJ's is OJ right Kevin Spacey is
up there Dana White is a bad f up it
ain't up there at the level of these
guys no like you know what I'm saying so
so there's the levels to f up to f up
you you want to do whatever you can to
have the massive F UPS in life it's
those are the ones you want to avoid as
much as possible because they are
permanent and no matter what you do as
much as we love Redemption we do love
Redemption this is America we're all
about Redemption certain F UPS it's uh
it's an asterisk that's right next to
you I want to go into Baseball Hall of
Fame you deserve to go like I believe
bonds belongs in a Baseball Hall of Fame
you can put pre pre-steroids post
steroids just you can say size of hats
seven and a quarter size of hat eight
and a quarter I mean that's all you got
to put you know what I'm saying so but
anyways props to Dana on the way he
handled it that was a great I think and
any major PR firm that you're going
through targeted by a media trying to
defame you which is going to happen as
you get bigger to Rogan they do it to
everybody rather than paying a half a
million dollars to PR from in New York
just called Dana White yeah how should I
handle this yeah or watch this handling
of Dana White it's a clinic he did I'll
add one thing number one he's giving a
master class on accountability and
Leadership you could you could be
accountable and be a leader even when
you [ __ ] up I think that's when you have
to be held accountable but you bring up
a very good point there's levels to
effing up a few weeks ago a month ago we
had our friend the liver King here he's
like
like you did steroids yeah you didn't OJ
and kill somebody two people you weren't
raping and pillaging I mean I don't know
what you do in your spare time ever
again I mean you got that look but all
we know is that you have done steroids
so like put in a little context he's
like thanks bro I appreciate it yeah but
he did lie to a lot of people but uh
Cosby and uh OJ that that's a different
level like you're right versus Tate or
liver king or whoever different levels
all right so let's continue to the next
door not good uh uh what we got here so
do we want to go to why don't we do uh
uh the Biden documents let's go on that
okay
how did discovery of classified files in
Biden's office Compares with Trump's
case now you know the story to be fair
is a uh what do you call it a story New
York Times so you know what New York
Times is going to be doing New York
Times is only going to see it from one
side it was reported that classified
documents were found in a private Office
of Joe Biden had used before beginning
2020 Campaign which prompted comparisons
to former president Donald Trump
hoarding of sunset documents which is
the subject of criminal investigation
both incidents involved office official
files bearing classification making the
improperly accompanied uh Trump and
Biden after they left office however
there are significant inferences in how
the documents came to light their volume
and how Trump and Biden responded Trump
and his aides resisted the government's
uh repeated efforts to retrieve them all
while Biden's lawyers reported a problem
in the White House says it has fully
cooperated Trump appeared to have
destroyed official documents appeared to
have destroyed there has been no
allegation that Biden destroyed public
records my question for you New York
Times is
who's rating Biden's house when when are
we doing that what what's the what's
that on the schedule when are people
going to go through all of his uh the
first ladies files or closet everything
should when when is that scheduled and
is the treatment going to be the same
for that to happen because the reaction
the reaction in a minute here I want to
actually play the clip with Peter Ducey
asking
every time I I can't pronounce it
what's her name who's the white house uh
Kareem Jean-Pierre okay Korean president
in a minute I just want you to see what
he asks and then he brings up the border
at the end okay before we watch it do me
a favor and go put it on 1.5 speed go to
the right there and go to 1.5 speed it's
a five minute clip we'll watch it in
three minutes but what are your thoughts
before we get to this clip here with
Peter Ducey a couple of things Pat Uh
first and I asked you this before we
walked in there are there any
Republicans that work for the doj do you
honestly think are there any Republicans
that work that's a great question for
the FBI or any of these people because
I'm I'm just curious because Adam and
I'm going back I'm going old school go
back to Hillary Clinton with with
Benghazi okay go to Hillary Clinton with
the emails from Loretta Lynch who was
the Attorney General to James Comey date
live in front of our faces change uh
like instead of what was it called well
instead of gross negligence which is you
go to jail it was extreme carelessness
these the Democrats take care of each
other bro I'm telling you right now and
from what I see it there's no
Republicans inside the doj because these
people get away with literally murder
they could do whatever the hell they
want and it's like well it comes back to
my point where fox has all these eyes
Fox is number one and everything fox has
all the viewership and we have all this
attention but nothing gets done are the
Democrats is the left that in charge Pat
like and I'm gonna be honest with you
nothing is going to come out about this
nothing is going to come out about fauci
fauci's not going to go to jail these
people are protected and all all it is
is is hey look we caught you and then we
just move on that's it that's all that
happens yeah you know I I kind of agree
with you and when I read the New York
Times article I I just want to look
around so I don't react react react I I
start looking around I'm like in a
private office in a locked closet well
where where was the private office and I
go looking around I found it's the Penn
Biden Center this is not a government
office that had badge readers and stuff
like that this is very similar to what
Trump had a private office at Mar-A-Lago
it's a locked closet at the Penn Biden
Center and by the way there's a second
stack of documents that have been found
in his second location so that Biden had
them in multiple locations so I I think
that there's a lack of intellectual
honesty about hey this is another
president that had documents off-site
not in a secure government location and
it was merely locked in a closet because
it was a locked closet at Mar-A-Lago too
by the way so I I'm kind of with you
Vinnie you know you start to read this
read between the lines and it's like
okay there's a pass okay there's another
pass okay there's a pass because they
just can't wait to get to the end of the
article and say see nothing to see here
yeah and exactly and I read this
yesterday that a large that that pen pen
uh that Center received 54 4 million
dollars that think tank from China so
it's kind of weird you know I mean you
just like and like you said there's no
security there's no they're just hanging
out there you know I mean they're just
no they're if you're gonna nail Trump
for a locked closet at Mar-A-Lago then
you mean the think tank at 54 million
okay that place got 54 minutes to nail
them yeah Trump what do you mean they
were taking dinner napkins that he had
from first of all just so put the stats
in place on what he's talking about the
think tank Biden's think tank in 2018
received 15.8 million dollars from
Anonymous Chinese gifts weird and then
three months later May of 2018 14 and a
half million dollar uh donation
Anonymous donation from China to UPenn
so this this is uh this is stuff that
should be and uh you know a hunter got a
one million dollars here from an
anonymous donor he sold an art piece and
he got paid so listen it's time to if
you guys want to investigate somebody do
you know what's the craziest thing let
me tell you what the craziest thing is
do you know how sometimes you have a
guy that used to work with me and he
would come in and he would uh he would
say you guys are doing this and he's
doing this and that person's doing this
and I'm like damn so at first I'm a
newer sales leader he's accusing so
imagine you're accusing him of doing
something and then you accuse Rob of
doing something and accusing him doing
something like oh [ __ ] man this guy's
three years later you know what it was
everything you accuse others of doing
you were doing yeah
to Democrats the strategy they're using
if you notice a trend what they do
Republicans don't necessarily do this
Democrats will say Trump's got Russia
he's colluding Russia no it was Hillary
oh you know what this is a travesty for
you to have files no president no person
in a it was really Biden
oh you know when it comes down to taxes
these guys don't want to give back and
they don't want to pay taxes you pull up
their charity they barely give any money
to charity to anybody Democrats are
divorce I give them money to charity oh
these guys don't want to care about
people you care about people so it's
it's almost as if it's only like the kid
that points out the other kid in your
family like you got kids one kid is
pointing out another kid what he doesn't
do it's the kid that doesn't do it so
it's a very interesting thing that they
keep getting caught I just want you to
watch us here let's play this we're
playing it on 1.5 and watch the
questions Peter Ducey asks and watch
your reaction and in the comments
section in the chat section you write
down the questions he's asking fair and
her reaction to it go ahead Rob
first does President Biden have
confidence in the transportation
secretary yes why because secretary
booty judge is a uh is he respects uh
the secretary and the work that he has
been doing uh you have seen the
secretary on TV you've spoke probably
spoken to him you've seen him on TV
doesn't work
experience
yeah it's a good one that's why they've
held the airlines accountable you've
seen the secretary do that over and over
again and we understand we understand
what uh what Americans have been going
through these past couple of months
that's why the secretary has been very
clear uh on making sure that they are
held accountable has put in a processes
in place to make sure that that occurs
and yes the president has confidence in
Senator and then on these documents how
could anyone be that irresponsible
it's not what the President says about
my family classified documents the
presidents will do this personally he
spoke to this personally he again he
believes that uh classified documents
and information should be taken
seriously he takes them seriously and he
was surprised to learn by any any
records I disagree I disagree here's
what happens here's what happened once
in history well let me let me explain to
you the process here's what happened
when uh his lawyers found out that the
documents were there they immediately
turned them over to the archives right
but they immediately start to turn them
over to the office I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna go into specifics but yeah what
I'm reiterating to you is what you heard
from the president yourself Peter uh
which is hypocrisy at its best and how
he respects and truly uh America is
getting sick take this very seriously
and when he knew and how surprised he
was by it and the actions that the right
actions that the lawyers took again this
is under this is under investigate this
is under review by the Department of
Justice and we're going to let that
process continue how can President Biden
be trusted moving forward with American
Secrets because his lawyers his team did
the right thing if he had a closet
lawyers did the right now again two
classes dude he was surprised that the
records were there he spoke to this but
personally he was surprised that the
records were there and when his lawyers
found out and his team found out that
they were there they turned it over to
the archives and now it's being reviewed
by the Department of Justice and just
one more why didn't President want to
see what's really going on at the border
he did see exactly what's going on yeah
you didn't talk to any migrants and you
didn't know anywhere that people
actually crossed illegally he can stop
it here yeah positive so you see that
what what are your thoughts Adam on her
reaction
well obviously her job is to defend the
president let's I mean whether it's uh
Huckabee Sanders or Caitlin mcenany or
Sean Spicer like your job is to
represent the president I just think I'm
at a point where I don't think either
side has a monopoly on being righteous
and I don't think either side has a
monopoly on lying cheating and stealing
so
what do I actually think I think Trump
did some shady [ __ ] and I think Biden
did some shady [ __ ] and I think both
sides are going to call each other don't
do that right now no no don't do that
Adam I just did
great you came to moving forward we want
to ask you for your Council but what I'm
saying no no but listen to me isolate
the concern isolated don't don't give a
[ __ ] answer like that why is that
[ __ ] I think they're both that's
like copping out answer I don't think so
isolate the concern in this case
where a person judges the other person
which Biden judge Trump trump never
judged Biden on this area Biden's
judging Trump on what he did then he
does it what do you think about this
isolated incident
I'll give you a special cancer and don't
give a cop-out answer everybody does it
that's a cop-out answer give us a really
in-depth analysis of what you think
about I'm not going to give an answer
that you want to hear it's not about my
opinion but it's not about what we or
the audience listen no no hang on one
second it's 2023. we have to improve you
have to improve hear me out no no listen
this conversation we had the other the
other day together don't give a copper
answer
give a real answer if somebody like if
you ask me like right now okay if you
ask me with Trump I won't sit there and
give an answer about well you know this
this I'm going to say that's a screw-up
of what just happened here you're
hearing this guy they go raid his house
they're going to the wife's closet
public FBI Garland everything SWAT team
then you hear something like this and
you say they both lied that's my answer
you think by the way if the show is for
the audience you think the audience won
with that answer that okay
I'm asking to ask you a real question
here you think the audience ones with
that kind of an answer
yes because I'll tell you why
can I go ahead all right number one I'm
I'm saying that Biden [ __ ] up and he
is this is hypocrisy you did not say
that though I'm gonna you're now saying
it said that I said that he's guilty of
hypocrisy and that no party has a
monopoly on righteousness and lying
cheating and stealing we just had a
conversation with Neil deGrasse Tyson
who in his entire book broke down the
fact that both [ __ ] lie and
that the Republicans are the party of
family values and Republicans preach
Family Values well if you actually look
at the numbers it turns out that the
people who stayed married the most the
longest and get the least divorced are
the people in Massachusetts
well I'm not isolating concerned because
there's a part of a macro perspective is
that Biden lied and he's cheating and
stealing and Hunter bidens guilty that
doesn't mean the fact that Trump didn't
lie cheat and steal I think they're
awesome so just so sure I caught but I
don't think that they're both I don't I
don't think so you're saying that
Biden's guilty but Trump's no I think
everything I think I think part about
this specific thing of hypocrisy
of hypocrisy if you're going to bring
that up and to say you know it's both
sides no both sides don't make fake
narratives about Russia for three years
and talk about them people like you
believe it okay both sides don't create
fake narratives about what's going on
with you know files and they go to his
place and embarrass the [ __ ] out of the
guy and that's never happened in the
history of America to president both
sides don't do it only one side does
that if you're asking like Trump is true
no unfairly I'll say yes but it's not
but it's not like Trump didn't shoot
himself
if we haven't the next topic we're going
to is Trump CFO what are you talking
about the next topic I'm about to go
into my point exactly because he did
shady [ __ ] also no it's called isolate
the issue you if I'm if I'm having a
conversation with a person and the
conversation is around an issue that's
this issue don't give me another but but
yes we all agree but but but in this
area if you look okay what is the what
is the what is the criticism I give
Republicans what is the criticism I give
Republicans what is it
okay what is the criticism I give to
Christians why was I an atheist for 25
years why am I very careful and
uncomfortable about talking about the
fact I go to church on Sundays why am I
very uncomfortable with trying to like I
I don't even want to almost advertise
that part like I'm a Christian why why
don't I do that do you know why I don't
do that because too many people from the
other side use that as a way to be
Almighty and judge the other people to
be perfect and behind closers they're
doing some [ __ ] self-righteousness but
that is a isolated concern to that area
that is the criticism they deserve in
this one here on this isolated issue
this is hypocrisy this right here when
you're sitting there just a few months
ago you're acting holy and knowing do
you know how many presidents and VPS
have a Declassified paperwork at their
house do you know how many of them have
had it tell me every one of them all of
them but but no it's not it's not okay
it's the okay
where when Trump had it for people to
say yeah that's we all have it no no
they turned it into the end of the
freaking world and when this guy has
said what does Joy Behar say Joy Behar
says well listen this is really what it
comes down to I trust Biden and I don't
trust you yeah great great and I'm sorry
no trust Plies is what you said that's
and that's what I want to hear from you
on this topic if it's a topic about
Trump let's one time Donald Trump Jr is
out there and they give this speech with
him and Kimberly Guilfoyle do you
remember that one time they give the
topic and we're like what the hell were
they on do you remember that one time
you're on a Hammerly Guilford gave a
speech clearly on cocaine okay okay but
but the point is this we don't hold back
from having ish having opinions on
issues this right here is purely
hypocrisy this right here is hypocrisy
in this sense and they're not being held
accountable to it he's getting away with
murder what Hunter's done none of
Trump's kids have anything but the way
the market sells it but Trump's kids are
bad and hun you know Biden's kids are
good they don't they they'll do a
softball interview with a guy like you
know Hunter well listen life's been hard
hasn't it yeah and look and you're
trying to change what's wrong with that
Jimmy Kimmel does an interview like that
and next thing you know the interview
with the other guys so on this part here
Adam this is not they're both liars
both sides of politics lie that part of
the question is out the window this is
which one uses the level of manipulation
the way that they do nobody uses
manipulation like the left nobody the
right acts righteous annoying the left
manipulates they divide that is their
level of expertise this is the whole
concept with this part here you sit
there and you act like your people on
your side well I trust those guys but
the other guy God forbid like right now
have you seen what's going on with
Stephen A Smith right now have you seen
how much hate he's getting Stephen A
Smith I I saw a little bit before we
walked anyway Smith is getting uh hey
just because he's running a podcast and
he's having uh uh Sean Hannity on all
right it's having all these other people
on it's like how could you have somebody
like that on there bro I want to talk to
these guys yeah just like you yeah I
want to talk to these guys so Iranian
people calling me why are you having
Reza aslano do you know he's not yet do
you know he's this I don't care I enjoy
it yeah I want to have these people on
but as we're going and we're talking
topics
I want us to give isolated issues with
this rather than just a lazy comment of
saying everybody's doing it we don't
benefit from that we actually want to
know how you think about it
yeah well number one just to be clear I
started off the entire conversation with
saying this is hypocrisy but I also am
able to walk and chew gum at the same
time and say hey you know what this
specific incident seems shady as hell
and should be investigated but from a
macro perspective I think they're all
freaking shady and I think they're all
two-faced and I think that they're all
up to no good so I think it's a level of
media and media scrutiny so on one hand
it's like well you know if you're
complaining about what the left's doing
then [ __ ] do it also Republicans okay
like don't let just let oh they have a
strategy that's working well why don't
you use it oh there's too many
professors in the uh in school that are
liberals well why don't you go get some
freaking jobs Republicans oh there's oh
the media has a a monopoly on what
they're saying well start a [ __ ]
Media company so what I'm saying is like
there's there's isolated incidents and
there's macro perspectives I happen to
think that Trump did some shady ass [ __ ]
and he should be held accountable I also
think that Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
have done some shady ass [ __ ] and they
should be held accountable and my my
entire Point here is stop mudslinging
and food fighting at the other team and
hold everybody accountable and that's
where I stand on yeah unfortunately Adam
the problem with what you're saying what
no one can sit here and tell us we only
bring one-sided guests no one can say
that correct okay all right so no one's
gonna sit here and say we only bring
people we agree with or we only do this
or even us at the panel here that we
have that we all 100 agree with no one's
going to say that about us we'll sit
there we'll have the conversation and
we'll still go have lunch today and not
have a problem we're isolating this
concern to show how one side is being
treated versus another side you know
when you have when you when you're going
to have kids here soon when you have
multiple kids you know what's the most
annoying thing that kids get frustrated
with parents when you ever want them
more than the other assuming when it's
double standards this morning this
morning we have a we have a new rule now
the kids have to be out of the house by
a certain time or else the kid that
caused being late owes a buck to the
other two okay one of our kids today was
late by one minute he owes the other two
a buck you know what's going to happen
he's going to come but that's not fair
but he's gonna say let me tell you I'm
fair with all of you guys when that
person is late when this person's late
you got to do the same exact standards
here's what you got they're not doing
that the way the deal they being the doj
is the reason why you ask the question
saying what are the Republican
Republicans on the doj like you really
think the doj is going to investigate
and get to the bottom of it no way we
just found that FBI the government's
been spying on us like oh we're gonna
investigate this so let me get this
straight it's like saying Adam I think
your taxes have been a little bit off
Adam says you know what let me go audit
myself yeah I'm gonna go audit myself
and what's the reason though
I I don't I literally don't know the
answer but Vinnie brought up the
question how many Republicans in the doj
well is it because there's a is there a
Democrat president because that Twitter
FBI and the doj is in bed together yeah
but how does that happen that's what I'm
saying so check this out don't just
recruit so Democrats here's a question I
dare you to go on CNN and MSNBC and
actually look how many times they've
they've covered the Twitter files you
know what the answer is I have no doubt
that it's not that much but but do you
realize how important that is that the
government is telling Twitter
to silence certain influencers and
certain stories not to post something
and channels were taken down who real
life people who rely on the source of
income just because they had a different
position than the government somebody
from the White House called and said
shut that person's account Down clean
that person place up that's not both
sides that's one side that's doing this
that's the part that it's isolating this
issue that is the part we can isolate
the issue of people on the right in
church and how righteous and all that we
can isolate the issue with Catholics
church we can isolate the issue with
every single thing that we do in this
area when it comes down to people being
held accountable historically the left
is rarely held accountable when it comes
down to institutions such as doj FBI and
others and stories recently they're in
China and there's yeah recent not
historian I would say yeah exactly
myself just from the video that Rob
played from the just the White House
briefing do you have you realized that
difference of remember the White House
briefings during during Trump let's say
with Sarah hucking me from all of them
it was a [ __ ] show people were yelling
everybody dude you couldn't even speak
in there do you see how right now it's
just one guy it's Peter Ducey he asked
his he's not even he's not aggressive
like uh Jim Acosta no sir sir Mr
President it was a [ __ ] show now it's
like everybody's behaved because they're
all on the same team they're quiet you
realize there's only one guy in that
whole goddamn room asking tough
questions and they laugh about it she
tells them the [ __ ] story and they
move on it's like look at the but this
this goes back to the initial point that
I made in the in the first part of the
podcast was why Greg Gutfeld is winning
the uh late night TV Awards because
who's getting into journalism who's
going into journalism School who's
becoming writers who are the professors
so you're complaining about the effect
what's the cause what's the symptom of
this is that more live liberal leaning
people are getting into news media
entertainment writing performance so
what do you think it's going to be
biased we talk about liberal media bias
so all you conservatives out there
encourage your kids to become better
writers and get into liberal arts and go
into Media or just
same old same old status quo so what I'm
saying is like yes you are right yes you
are correct yes there is liberal media
bias yes they don't cover a lot of
stories what are you going to do about
it because you already know the answer
you just complain about it that's one
part of it that's all we do are you
gonna raise your kids until your kids to
go to college and so that's what I'm
saying it's like I agree but there's a
bigger perspective out there that's all
I'm saying about don't ask you really
really quick so someone that's me that's
frustrated because I never knew what
left or right was until 9 11 when I was
in the military and then I started
seeing everything bro from the lies to
the truth so I'm where I'm at right now
are the is it is one side so in control
because we're seeing it right now that
with all the stuff that the left gets
away with the right they hold them to
the fire but are we just screwed in the
fact that like all this stuff could come
out from the Twitter thing to buy it
into the uh all the classified and
nothing's gonna happen nothing's gonna
happen tonight
none of them no no I don't think that's
the case I just I just think it's not
going to happen right way I do think
this can eventually happen I do think
eventually you know the the way the
house flips when one side abuses power
when they have it here's a problem when
you're so powerful you use your powers
to bully
all you're doing is developing
a delay time bomb of the other side
getting also more powerful so they're
going to retaliate and bully you
there's a reason why when somebody has
all the power in the world and they
don't bully they gain respect to say hey
this Marcus Aurelius guy meditations yet
all the power in the world but the
people loved you for the seven years you
were there from 60 to 80 to 69 A.D
people loved you because the way he was
with his people and he had a slave
sitting behind him telling them hey just
so you know you're a nobody you're a
regular guy you're not that special a
guy whispered that to his ears you're
Immortal yeah you're mortal you're gonna
die your distance like that he needed
that as a reminder
this is going to keep going back and
forth and it's not going to be pretty on
the other side when they come and get
them but at the same time
it is true that people are sitting there
like right now on Twitter
you know another student yesterday uh
unfortunately had a heart attack and
died 21 years old yeah 21 years old this
this keeps happening right a lot and and
guess who cares about that kid's life
the most and who's going to investigate
the cause of it the most his parents his
parents okay and and do you think
parents are ever going to forget that no
no ever ever parents are gonna sit there
and do as much due diligence as possible
just like Robert De Niro who cannot
stand Donald Trump can't even control
himself but when but ask about his 23
year old son go ahead and ask uh how he
feels about certain ways things are
handled go ask about his 23 year old
autistic son and so see what how strong
opinions he's got when it becomes
personal to your life
politics don't matter anymore things
change and more and more people are
starting to ask these questions say why
can't we hear the opposing side there's
a video that went viral yesterday
commercial that was made I posted on
Twitter I don't want to share it because
we're on YouTube platform right now it's
called the Kauffman Institute of
coincidence okay oh do you see this
video or no have you guys seen this or
no the Kauffman Institute have you seen
this commercial Kaufman Institute of
coincidence yeah people are start to ask
why is this happening and why is it not
being investigated so Jon Stewart he
ain't no Republican he's he's the guy
that's going to say how come we're not
investigating where the virus leak from
and the answer is what nowadays who
cares it's over it's done is done yeah
okay what do you mean what's done is
done yeah what's done is done hey the
studies are coming out saying the people
that got the
you know are the ones most susceptible
to continuing the next variant of it
well you know it's it's listen stop
being paranoid
stop being paranoid those people who
have been pushed like that you know Joe
and I were talking last night two nights
ago he sent me a uh four articles to
read about uh uh what's going on with uh
uh after our podcast with Neil deGrasse
Tyson
and we're talking and he did a great
podcast with him he's on multiple
podcasts with him and uh he said you may
want to go listen to Rogan yeah and
Rogan did a podcast with Brett Weinstein
okay I'm gonna give you the time lap
time I want you to listen after this
podcast I want you to go download Joe's
podcast I'll tell you which time to go
just three and a half hours but wait
till the end for me to give you the time
to listen to it and we'll put in the
comment section in the chat put it at
the top comment it above at the top so
people if they want to go listen Maybe
put in the description so people can see
it I'll give you the exact time
him and Brett aren't having a
conversation and this is why people love
Joe Rogan this is why everybody in the
world has to watch this clip it's nine
minutes
and he says well we have to hold these
people accountable and just says no no
no I disagree I disagree let me tell you
why he says look I've been wrong many
times
there are a lot of people that disagreed
with me some that took it and now they
regret it
I almost took it when I first did the
first podcast with Michael this I almost
took it I almost thought about it and
then I did research and I felt bad and I
just said if we are constantly going to
be judging people for mistakes that they
made we're not going to make progress we
have to forgive them we have to be
charitable
I mean he sounded like a pastor I'm not
and he's not he's like the furthest guy
from wanting to be a pastor that message
was so flipping powerful because he says
that's the mindset like yesterday this
guy named Dr Shiva can you pull up the
go to Twitter he tweets something
and says something about the Dr Neil uh
uh the grass Tyson just go just go to my
Twitter account go to my Twitter I
retweeted his tweet if you go to my
Twitter account go to my Twitter account
you go to my Twitter account he tweet
something and he trolls uh what's his
name he trolls uh uh uh Neil deGrasse
Tyson okay go down hopefully these
tweets will show up go lower go lower if
you can go lower I hope it's not
disappeared keep going keep going song
bro oh my God you have to hear the song
keep going lower I hope it doesn't do
what it does uh it's right there okay
right there right there at the bottom at
the bottom at the bottom so click on
that one perfect perfect so zoom in into
Dr shiva's tweet Dr shiva's tweet okay
so he says Neil deGrasse Tyson
your claim everyone must be vaccinated
for the collective good is ignorant as
an MIT PhD in systems biology let me
educate you on the immune system so your
head May emerge out of Uranus oh wow I'm
sure Patrick by David will host okay Dr
Shiva now by the way to to give him
credit this guy is potentially
recognized for inventing email yeah
he's not like a regular guy female no no
this guy is a invented heavyweight so
here's my response to him here's what I
said to him I said your approach is part
of the problem both sides tend to come
across arrogant pompous and not willing
to budge which doesn't create a climate
to have a healthy scientific debate both
sides can be wrong and right at the same
time and that's okay which is where
people win okay so what's the point here
you're inviting a guy to want to debate
you but you're doing it in a way the
guy's not going to do this okay so so so
the challenge here is
in this argument yes the left may have
had vaccine wrong yeah and everybody
needs to sit there and say hey guys
listen
if you're Catholic we got some things
wrong if you're this we got something's
wrong can we all improve can we
synergize and come together or what is
it that we're going to be doing well we
have to isolate concerns and issues and
address them head on this area you guys
screwed up that area we spent too much
money in military this area Iraq was a
waste that area the way we left
Afghanistan was a mistake that area
Ukraine you were using it to make money
this area North Korea does that area
Terrace China was the right move that
area Iran why are we giving these guys
their money back that we have to isolate
each concern and realize that on both
sides if we isolate them we will notice
a nobody makes a hundred percent of the
decisions the right way right the one
area that the left has a monopoly on is
manipulation it's the
[Music]
my question is so you said this year was
going to be the year of Investigations
do you think it's going to turn into the
like convictions or that's my question
here's here's what I want my ideal
situation is to let's just find out what
happened and I want to find out what
happened and move on not let's just move
on I mean it's over with already anyways
let's find out what happened and then
move on Tate okay let's talk about Tate
uh I I don't think we need to say
anything for people to realize we like
what he says and how he challenges uh
the people of power and he goes and
targets them and all that stuff he's a
very very very good communicator by the
way potentially the best Communicator in
the world today he could potentially be
the best Communicator in the world today
and I don't know if I put anybody ahead
of him wow who do you put ahead of him
he's a communicator he's a talk he's an
incredible Communicator the way he
delivers his message right okay
all right so
he's trying to get out of a uh you know
he's still in detention uh uh trying to
end Detention of Romania they're not
giving him the opportunity to come out
who knows what's going to end up
happening with this year we're in talks
with his lawyer I'd like to talk to his
lawyer to have him on and uh to have a
kind of fair conversation with him just
some questions that I want to ask this
guy we'll see what happened there all
right so you look at Tate with this
scenario
some things came back with Vice a
recording of a guy that he once
interviewed with that started asking him
all these questions and then tastes like
men where are you going with this they
stopped the interview that guy follows
up and finds the girls
gets recording now Vice is coming out
with something today no one knows what's
going to be said but some of the uh
WhatsApp recordings came back and you
know certain statements that he made etc
etc and everyone's texting me saying you
support this guy you support that you
support this you support that
I'm able to isolate
areas
that Tate crushes
the globalist and crushes the people of
power that love to bully
and I'm able to isolate that and say man
what a freaking way of doing it good for
you guy keep challenging the status go
and keep pushing these guys but I'm able
to isolate and say
what are you doing
sending audio recordings on WhatsApp do
you think you're untouchable none of us
are and then I'm able to isolate and see
his relationship with his brother
and say man tell me you wouldn't want to
have a brother that has your back the
way they have each other's back and then
I'm able to isolate and in my own mind
say what was the upbringing like to have
a father and a mother the way they did
him the two of them and their sisters
and kind of say maybe and then isolate
and why they fought and isolate how
disciplined they are in certain and then
isolate and
hey what you're doing with the way
you're making money and isolate you you
ought to be able to isolate these
different areas instead of just saying
hey uh everybody falls in the same camp
no and again earlier when we were
talking about you know how about this
person does that person get the 50 50
all this stuff we still don't know
things still got to come out to see
what's going to happen with this and
when we have the conversation with the
lawyer we'll have follow-ups uh uh you
know so that's the part when you're
looking at this we have to isolate and
see what happened with covet who got it
wrong did fauci get it wrong let's
isolate let's address this and let's
make sure it never ever happens again
right we had audio issues today on the
podcast this is the second time in two
days you know my message was to our guys
guys this can't happen we have to
isolate this concern what is causing it
let's get to the bare bottom of what is
caused the root cause of this so once we
learn what happened with covet who left
up we got to move on if out she f'd up
and used powers and other people Empower
them they got to be held accountable
what the hell happened with Afghanistan
we just lost 8 82 billion hours of
weapons there what the hell happened
with Iraq 20 years you know what
happened now what happened with Iran
what happened with this isolate move on
learn and cause people to realize
if you do this again and you use this
method of abusing people to make money
you take deals from other countries and
you give access to them of what we're
doing Insider information you deserve to
go to jail isn't there a name for that
what's the name for that it's a treat no
no what happens when you're given the
enemy information
listen and by the way I'm convinced
Benedict Arnold I'm convinced there was
some of that that happened the last few
years those people it's the ultimate
accountability I agree 100 the ultimate
accountability which is why if we by the
way I'll pause you I've been going for a
minute any thoughts you guys got on Tate
I'll pause because I want to go into the
Prince Harry stuff and then we'll wrap
it up well I think I think what you're
basically saying is not everyone is all
good and all bad we all have a little
bit of black and white and it's not all
black and white everyone has a little
gray area I agree with you that on one
hand I could think Tate is a freaking
stud an awesome speaker and has a great
message and male empowerment and
self-improvement and that's awesome and
a lot of what he says I fully fully
fully added Advocate and agree with but
I could also sit here and be like he
might have done some of this sex
trafficking [ __ ] I don't know I wasn't
there none of us were so to blindly
trust someone and blindly follow them is
is gonna get yourself in hot water
whether it's republican or democrat or
this influence for that influencer and I
agree with you everything should be
what's a term that you like to to use uh
that you've been using for the to
isolate isolate yeah so yeah I think if
you want to isolate each of the
components of what Tate stands for I
think there's a lot more positive than
negative I think that's what great
coaches do the Excellence listen Johnny
you got you're you're our best defender
yeah but man you're lazy to get that
rebound yeah okay great job on the
defense side you're terrible on the you
know and in the locker room sometimes
you say stuff that's off you know like
you [ __ ] too much like bring the team
together we have to isolate areas but
it's like it's like um you ever play uh
video games Madden Sports yeah and they
give every athlete their breakdown their
score all right so Hustle so they're 92
percent offense they're 85 percent
defense they're only 62 percent effort
teammate and everyone has their
different score in different categories
right like I try to I every day I say
health wealth happiness health wealth
happiness all right how's my health
today [ __ ] feel great I'm doing it I
just worked out yeah I kind of went out
and drank too much I had my health did a
wealth all right I make some money all
right now paycheck the paycheck whatever
happiness am I happy am I not like I'm
constantly one through tening myself and
your score can constantly be be
malleable and moving around so to get
back to Tate there's a lot of high
scores a lot but there's also some high
negative scores that could end up biting
you in the ass yep so I don't know what
are your thoughts on tonight I'm happy
that you said it too and my thing is uh
uh everything that you said it's like
and I think we can't be quick to judge
because I mean we do Americans love
doing that [ __ ] oh right we saw rape
that's no it's like you don't know [ __ ]
I don't know I wasn't there there I
don't know nothing about this guy in
that capacity and but you could overhear
now especially with all this Ai and all
this [ __ ] any voice recording now it
might not even be you I don't trust any
of that [ __ ] bro I don't trust any of it
I saw a video where somebody made uh uh
Barack Obama was sitting there and
speaking it wasn't him it looked exactly
like him and this was years ago bro who
knows that so like I said we're quick to
judge slow down give the person the
benefit of the doubt until it's real but
then you nail it held him accountable
when this [ __ ] does come out so we'll go
back to Pat and we'll wrap this up but I
think what we're really talking about
here is the thing called intellectual
honesty and intellectual analogy this is
going in to evaluate something isolating
the issue and just being really
objective about what you see and the
weakest Debaters you will ever encounter
are the ones that have to slip in the
but what about them or not as bad as the
other and that's the whole pendulum
thing it's like they can't
intellectually honestly look at
something isolated evaluate it with a
critical eye and objectivity and then
leave it be they it represents a threat
to their side so they gotta pull in the
other bit but what about them but it
wasn't as bad as this and that is just
weak-willed arguing that that great
jurists in this country when you read
about the Supreme Court Justice and some
of the great jurists we've had have the
ability what they call it's not carrying
a rope into the into the uh into the
courthouse right you're not bringing in
something with you that's going to judge
your ultimate decision you
intellectually honestly look at it and I
think that's what we're talking about
here and I think that the media's lost
the way to do it and I think if you look
at yourself in the mirror at times you
each one of us loses the ability to do
that and this is what Pat's talking
about isolate it judge it assess it to
the benefit of our audience wants to
know and wants to hear these let's use
let's move on I mean meaning isolate and
let's move on yeah okay so last thoughts
here Harry uh uh record-breaking day
sold 1.45 million copies day one in US
UK and Canada a bunch of different
things that came out it's not again like
I said it's not like he needs us to
promote it anymore the guy's already on
track to being the you know most selling
by the way there was a Wall Street
Journal video the other day I watched on
how these guys make money 120 million
dollars from Netflix apparently he is a
chief something of a company c-suite
executive of a company he gets 120 Grand
year there they bought their 40 million
dollar house and uh what is it uh
somewhere in Santa Barbara what is that
one place in Santa Barbara the high-end
Community Tom that Oprah Winfrey lives
in there's an area there's Carpinteria
there's Montecito Montecito yeah but
it's now this week
that's true it is bad so anyways you
want to tell a couple of the stories
Vinnie on what happened so yeah I read a
New York Post that uh Prince Harry he
bitterly believed that he was only bred
to offer literal spare parts for his
brother in case his Heir a parent ever
needed new organs and he said and I
quote two years older than me Willy was
the heir whereas I was the spare which
is nuts he goes I was a shadow the
support the plan B I was bought into the
world in case something happened to
Willie and he said um he understood his
role was a diversion and distraction
from his brother uh kidney blood
transfusion uh bone marrow and he also
noted King Charles III could never be on
the plane with his Elder son because uh
there must be no chance of his first and
second in line to be thrown to be wiped
out yeah that's bro can you imagine like
real I mean he he didn't just randomly
come up with that I can't believe he
wrote it but seeing your brother and
going I was only put here just God
forbid something happens you know that
you use me
such an ultimate and by the way the way
succession works is as soon as William
starts having kids they're in front of
you yeah so when you talk about spare
you become spare and then spare three
spare four spare five because all of
William's kids are in front of Harry
well I don't think that's as crazy as it
seems because of this book because
that's just how the monarchy works it's
your firstborn son since since Abraham
Isaac Jacob Moses Jesus that's just
since the tale is all this time it's the
firstborn son that inherits the throne
that's just kind of how it works and
then it didn't help that as kids uh
William was this good-looking blonde
blue-eyed and he and then Harry's
literally the red-headed stepchild so
like it it didn't help his cause but
yeah ironically somehow you know now
that William has kind of lost his hair
ain't the hot stuff anymore
Harry's where it's at but Harry kind of
was able to fly under the radar there's
a lot of things that Harry was able to
do
because he wasn't the heir to the throne
okay what was that corrupted just posted
a comment 20 Super Chat shout out to you
poor Harry is the most abused woman in
the last 50 years
that's hilarious what's funny was that
my question was is Harry a pimp or is he
a Sim oh because the whole knock on him
is like
how good and this is a little this is a
little rated R right here how good must
this girl be Meghan Markle oh God pretty
people like yeah I'm out I'm out of the
throne I'm out of the monarchy I'm just
rolling with my girl now
they're um
her skills must be all right I don't
know if it's just her I think there's a
lot of things that are in this book from
the family that was there uh as well and
he found a girl that he loved and he's
being loyal to her I respect that but
there's a lot of this goes in here that
predates her of just growing up number
two and everything that went around it
and
Kamala and how that relationship
happened him just saying this is how it
happened this is how I felt you said I
didn't believe me I didn't read the book
not even one sentence but you're saying
there's stuff that you relate to because
he he loves his girl and he's just gonna
give it all no I think I think it's
respect what he he's defending his wife
of respect but let's isolate it the
defense of his wife is here and now he's
talking about a lot of other things over
here like his dad getting divorced his
mom dying all the things there that
predated his wife so there's a Pantheon
of things in the book to talk about his
various chips and and insults and uh you
know the things that he's really
resentful of and then he gets he falls
in love he gets married and he's like
okay this is Redline you know what Bill
Clinton once said I don't know where I
saw this where are my cigars no he said
one time where the hoes at was that not
it yeah I'm actually giving it
here so yeah
guys stop for a second so one time she
said
um
uh he said uh asking question about his
mom apparently his mom was bipolar or
something like that and he says there's
literally no benefit for me saying
anything about my mom anything bad about
my mom
yeah to me Rob you're Mike to me that's
social intelligence is what that is okay
for somebody to say there's literally
nothing beneficial of Me no no good
comes from me criticizing my mother you
can't even find it like wow and so it's
a book hypomanic Edge talks about him
and another one called first-rate
madness talks about him talks about
Jackson talks about Kennedy and I I uh
I don't know I have a very hard time
with us
recognizing uh somebody
trashing his parents that made him
relevant in the first place and the
family you came out of if you weren't
from that family you would have sold
five copies of your book on day one the
only reason you sold one and a half
million copies
is because of your lineage and your
family
and and to allow a woman
to be okay with you trashing that Legacy
I have a very hard time with that
character
uh uh of uh of that um of the duo very
very hard but do you think and I agree I
agree 100 but but do you do you think
also the resentment that he has that
what they did to him and that he was a
spare even gave him more incentive to be
like you know what the hell guess what
certain things should be motivators that
you never tell anybody
um
certain things in life are great
motivators you never reveal to anybody
that's the Lie by the way you could have
been born in Compton you could have been
born in Liberty City
you could have been born in anywhere
else you happened to be born and you're
ungrateful like the average human being
whether they like him or not they have
to read that and say I don't give a [ __ ]
let make me a spare
can I despair are you kidding me like
what are you talking about bro like you
want me to cry about you being a spare
and because of that you saw 1.5 million
copies of your book I don't know I I I I
don't because what this is what what
we're recognizing and making okay is hey
you know why don't you go like you know
the whole uh uh kellyanne Conway family
with the daughter yeah I I don't I don't
I'm not a fan yeah this is why I never
once watched keeping up with Kardashians
I've never watched any of that stuff one
time I didn't I didn't watch it I'm not
a fan of what this uh whole story of uh
I mean listen you know who's loving it
whoever published the book who published
the book by the way is it Simon and
Schuster penguin I'm curious to know who
published this book whoever published
the book and convinced them and somehow
someway sold them on what to add the
juice to add in there the editor the
writer penguin Justin penguin you won
good for you yeah congratulations
penguin because penguin doesn't give a
[ __ ] they're like add more [ __ ] talk
more [ __ ] say more [ __ ] great boom good
for you I uh um
yeah I'm I'm good by the way don't be
surprised if in 40 years their kid
writes a book about them and tells the
truth about who Megan is this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is not a
you don't do that he even said he even
said he had before he got frostbite Tom
you were talking about this right here
he got he even dangling his dangling out
of frost yeah it's it's too much CMI bro
it was a party life and when I look back
and I say okay I can say all these
things he says he's offended and
resentful and then and then protecting
his wife
I objectively look at that but then I
also step back from it and say dude
you've lived like
the most insane privileged party enabled
life with unlimited allowance courtesy
of the British taxpayers
come on there's a part of me that says
okay I can read and I can objectively
understand how a person might feel these
ways but then you step back from it and
say dude do you remember when you
partied in Las Vegas you were like naked
for three days and all of the American
tabloids had you naked for three days
and it was like no consequence and you
were just this party animal and you
could do it because you were number two
if you had been number one in line you
couldn't do it and so you know now
you're writing a book and you're you're
milking this cow so I and I don't have a
lot of sympathy for that and I'm with
you on that point yeah I'll say one
thing about about to wrap up go ahead
yeah well the last thought here everyone
talks about a special I mean we're
talking about male female relations
intersectional Dynamics they're talking
about we're talking about a husband and
a wife here so a lot of times you hear
the the term like oh he's got game he's
got game where all that but there's
another term that they use in the
manuscript called holding frame and
holding frame would be I'm a freaking
Prince Meghan Markle yeah my fan family
is the is the monarchy of the UK of
Great Britain and Beyond
I'd go back and being a c-list actress
on suits or whatever the hell show she
was on or you could be a freaking
princess here's the catch though baby
you're coming into my world I'm second
aligned to the throne you're gonna lit
we can do whatever we want in this world
but this is part of it but I feel like
there's an element of his like this is
this is a representation of the
patriarchy and we're gonna tear this
down and you know female is the future
that whole thing and he's succumbed to
that rather than holding frame that's
why I think people lost a lot of reasons
gotta wrap up gotta wrap up hey uh Kai
uh uh okay so can you for some of you
guys that are texting me telling me Pat
we're about to cross 500 000 are we
gonna be doing that live podcast we are
here's the challenge it's gonna sell out
very quickly and many of you guys are
Die Hard Die Hard fans of that are
following the podcast and I want you
guys to be there so uh we'll be selling
tickets at our new building it's gonna
be done when the Cigar Lounge is done
with and it's gonna be sick when you
guys come through uh we don't know how
many people we're gonna be selling maybe
100 maybe 200 maybe 300 if you want to
be on that list what is the uh um can
you ask Kai real quick what is the Rob
if you got it Kai uh what's
give me one second take your time
can you imagine that phone call like Hey
listen your brother just one of his
testicles he got into a car accident
like all right I gotta come give mine
you know what I mean the spare part guy
uh what do you need
yo what happened this is really bad news
we need both kidneys yeah yeah listen
your brother lost one of his eyes so now
it's you we're taking it is is Kai
responding or no are you getting a hold
of him uh uh let me just get a hold of
Kai here give me one second call Mike oh
by the way Pat Uh when you you mentioned
my cologne
everybody's been messaged yeah this is
cologne yes by the way and what is stop
what is that clone I don't want to say
it because I'm not getting sponsored by
them so okay smart man thank you Adam
Kai give me their name so I can tell
everybody to text so they're on their
list because we have 2 000 Subs until we
cross 500 000. what's the word at least
it's not that aramist stuff from 1985.
real quick we're live
mm-hmm
[Music]
is he speaking English Norwegian is he
nor we is he speaking English
what language is he speaking the time is
money Kai here's what we're gonna do you
just tell them text the word podcast to
310-340-1132 the word podcast text it
310-340-1132 the word podcast to
310-340-1132 we will let you know the
moment tickets are for sale we'll send
it but keep this in mind
when you get it get the tickets because
it will sell out just when we're only
gonna do this one time the next one
we're gonna do we add a million Subs but
when we sell it it's gonna sell out so
once again three one zero three four
zero one one three two text the word
podcast to us take care everybody
bye-bye bye bye tomorrow vivec ESG
podcast we're back at it again bye-bye
bye bye bye